certain firefighters made calls to their
families because they weren't sure they
were going to make it out of that
situation for them to then be blamed
had that building been cluttered
properly that fire wouldn't have spread
like the way it did
hi hello hey so lovely to meet you
look nice to meet you
when did you join the fire service nice
easy question to start it's nice and
easy
but it's a very long time ago so it was
1982
and i was 17 years old and it was the
first time norfolk fire
service had done junior firefighter
course i joined
just under two years ago now oh wow yeah
in fact two years ago
next week i didn't know what i wanted to
do when i graduated union and
i knew i wanted to help people and do
something different every day and do
something active and
it's nice to be part of like a small
nice little team um
and this is always something i wanted to
do but to me it was always you know the
boys get to do it it's a boy
job they play with the toys and they
fight the fires and they save people's
lives
and yes i didn't really see any female 5
effects growing up and then i just one
day i thought you know
why not try it i might not get in if i
don't i'll try again
and then as soon as i got in i realized
i didn't want to do anything else
that was it that was it for me how many
women were there with you in training
there's 27 of us on our training school
and then uh five of us were girls
and did you all get through yeah that's
brilliant yeah isn't it
yeah i was the first female firefighter
in the uk
in the whole of the uk yeah feel like i
should have known about this
that's incredible i didn't join the job
to be able to go oh i was the first
female firefighter
i wanted a salary to get my own dorky to
be independent you know
in those days we had to have all our
hair kind of cut so no makeup no
no nothing yeah so i look like a boy and
i was always being mistaken for a boy
even one old lady rang her up her niece
and she was like
oh we just had these lovely firefighters
in or fireman she was
firemen and they put my chimney fire out
and you should one of them is so
handsome and she was looking straight at
me and i'm like
oh no she thinks i'm because i did it
like a young man handsome i mean
handsome young man what is the strangest
reason
you've come across for a fire starting
it would be something where you get
there
and they shouldn't have been doing
whatever they were doing you get some
strange
excuses we had one that was a candle
like a tea light it's because a guy had
um
he was trying to do something nice for
his girlfriend who was about to come
home she had a bad day and he was like
put some candles on he cleaned the flat
and they didn't have a holder for it so
they just had it on the kitchen worktop
and it burnt through the worktop all the
way through
and burnt through the top of the washing
machine and literally the kitchen
went up they just got the whole kitchen
just from a tea light sitting on the
kitchen worktop
and blessing he burnt like his hands and
his feet trying to sort it out and she
came home and the door was broken down
because of hers and
obviously we were like oh yeah clothes
have been on fire or any kitchen
most of the time we tend to see phone
chargers
like faulty phone chargers or cheap
phone chargers or unofficial ones
that's every house fire i've been to
pretty much
wow is that's how it started people
charging their phones on their bed
and just leaving it to it and
e-cigarettes as well that's a big thing
what's the hardest thing about being a
firefighter oh
going into something that is very
difficult to handle where you've got
maybe people
that you can't help for whatever reason
if it's you're too late perhaps if it's
an rta road
a road accident or you get to a fire and
it's too late and you
and also you you know the impact that
it's going to have to those people's
families don't you
it's the the chance that you could do
something that's not going to help
the feeling of sort of weighing up
endangering yourself and everyone else
but with the chance that you can get
someone out of it is a really hard
battle to have and you know if it goes
wrong
it's on you but if it goes right you've
saved someone's life so it's a sort of
is it the right thing to do or is it the
professional thing to do and it's a real
hard balance to find yeah the problem is
you can't carry it because you don't
know what the next job is going to be so
you've got to
go do it get out and carry on
quite recently actually we had a couple
of suicides of firefighters which
has been really hard and it's no one i
knew but my gaffney one of them very
well and
firefighters generally i got on very
well with because i think they're all
very similar very good people so knowing
that it's someone else in that position
and they didn't have anyone to speak to
about it or they didn't feel
capable of carrying on is a very strange
feeling i think
for everybody whether they met them or
not
how has grenfell changed things oh gosh
that's a big question
what did it feel like to be in the fire
service like the day after grenfell
having
you know kind of watched it my first
thought which is probably a very selfish
first thought
is what would i've done in that
situation if like
can you do anything and these people
have like they were in breathing
apparatus climbing however many flaws
and then trying to explain that to
people of like how much it weighs
like the kit and the you know like the
high rise packs and everything like that
you've got to carry up
the kit they were carrying and they were
climbing over people and
black stairwells and smoke logged and
not even nba yet and it's
a horrible imagine like a thought to
imagine it but i know i remember seeing
a picture of people sat outside who'd
already been in twice
in breathing apparatus and obviously now
the regulations are you may have a break
before you go in again
and i remember seeing a picture of them
just starting up again and going and
again with the fresh cylinder someone
was changing one on
their back just so they could go back in
again and it's been in that kind of
situation
you just want to get in and get out as
many people as you can there was that
documentary
about was it the fire service's fault
and i remember being so angry when i saw
it and so
hurt by it i know people that had made
calls to their families
because they saw it and when we're not
coming out of this firefighters certain
firefighters made calls to their
families
because they weren't sure they were
going to make it out of that situation
and to me for them to then be blamed had
that building been cluttered properly
that fire wouldn't have spread like the
way it did um
so it's a very strange thing of i know
that
we could have handled it but we would
have handled it the exact same way they
did it's
guidelines and regulations you've got to
follow but
i think being there and seeing that and
seeing people losing things and losing
their lives and
not knowing where anyone is is such a
horrible horrible position to be in
and i wouldn't wish on anybody i think
it'd be
i don't think i'd ever be okay seeing
something like that and i know there are
seven firefighters obviously still
recovering from it and still out of work
from it and it's just unimaginable no
you never recover with that
what are some common misconceptions of
women in the fire services
i think the main thing is the strength
that we're not as strong as the men
which you know biologically we're not
physically it's harder for us to build
up that strength but
the misconception that we can't do it
because of that always winds me up we've
had to pass the same tests we've had to
pass the same
physical standards and not one of the
girls that i
have worked with has ever struggled
my best friends in the job a couple of
those are female and they are some of
the best firefighters i've ever worked
with
the general impression is that men are
assumed that they can do it and women
are assumed that they can't so we have
to prove ourselves again and again and
again
yeah which i really struggled with the
first because i'm always trying to prove
myself and i hate being bad at things
but i'll always put myself forward to do
it to prove i can
and something everyone will say but you
don't go into the fires do you
you don't you don't go to the job surely
yeah
my gender doesn't mean i can't go into a
burning building
nowadays telling people say on a night
out or meeting
guys or trying to flirt and you tell
them you're a firefighter and that's a
very different reaction that's a very
like a oh
okay and then a immediate conversation
killer
my mum and dad were very positive about
it my mum's a really you know kind of
strong woman there's not a question as
to whether you can do something just go
and do it you know
only person i had a problem with was my
stepfather
his brother was a firefighter in a
nearby town
and he was like she'll never be able to
put a man
over her shoulders and he put this in
all the local paper it's like oh my gosh
it's like yeah watch me yeah that's it
was it part of it do you think sort of
i'm going to prove them wrong now always
yeah
what skills have you learned during your
service that have served you
in life i'd say it's made me a lot more
confident
a lot more resilient there's not been a
day that's gone by where i've not looked
forward to going to work
it's just you know if you see it as
messing about with your mates and having
a lovely time while still getting the
job done it's
the best job in the world it's exactly
what you make it
as a job it's so much fun isn't it i
can't believe we get paid to do that
i know it's just the best because it
made you a bit of an adrenaline junkie
yeah it was really lovely to meet you
take care you too
there's a knock on the door i open the
door
and there's a bunch of people standing
there none of them in uniform
one of them pulls out a gun pushes it to
my head
i know my family my wife and kids are in
the other rooms
and i tell them please leave them alone